Селище Гекалов неподалік від Грозного.
Типове чеченське село. Всі один одного знають,
всі один одному допомагають.
Незважаючи на високі паркaни.
Ось тільки про одне не говорять з сусідами - про зниклих дітей.
Петімаат Саламова теж довго мовчала
- майже чотири роки. Тепер вона перервала мовчання,
щоб розповісти нам про Заліну -
її дjньку, яка ось уже чотири роки
не з'являлася в бaтьківській хаті.
Заліна пішла за своїм чоловіком Русланом, який вирушив
до Сирії, аби приєднатися до так званої
"Ісламської держави". Угрупoвання,
забороненого в багатьох країнах, в тому числі і в Росії.
Він забрав Заліну і дітей. Їх у них троє.
Я не думаю, що він повернеться.
Нам сказали, що він загинув. Його немає з березня.
Він не повернеться.
Відтоді сліди Заліни Саламової губляться.
Вона -  одна із сотень чеченців, які залишили батьківщину
від початку війни в Сирії, аби стати на бік так званої
"Ісламської держави". За старою чеченською
традицією, дружини слІдують за чоловіками.
Скільки їх, точно нікому не відомо. За офіційними даними,
на боці ІД воюють близько восьмисот чеченців.
Практично всіх їх оголосили на батьківщині
"зниклими безвісти". Разом з дІтьми.
Ці фотографії передали DW їхні зневірені матерi.
Вони все ще сподіваються
отримати бодай якусь звісточку від своЇх дітей.
Знімальна група знову вдома у Петімаат. Її син
Анзор і внучка Сумая розглядають фотографії Заліни.
Чи може Анзор уявити собі, що він стане на бік терористів
і піде за своєю сестрою в Сирію?
"Чи не боїшся, що тебе теж можуть завербувати?"
Мене ніхто не зможе завербувати.
Тому що у мене свої міркування щодо цього, не можна так.
Петімаат все ще не втрачає надії на те, що одного дня її донька
повернеться додому.
Вона показує нам дитячий одяг, який вона купила своїм онукам.
І - ось цю фотографію!
Це я в Сирії знімала.
За останні чотири роки Петімаат змогла
лише один раз побачитися з донькою -
в кінці 2014-го.
Контакт із нею їй вдалося встановити за допомогою посередників.
Кілька тижнів вона добиралася
до міста Мембідж на півночі Сирії. Бойовики "ІД"
дозволили їй побути з донькою чотири дні.
Однак забрати свою родину до Чечні
їй не вдалося - ні доньку, ні онуків.
Про ту поїздку Петімаат знову і знову розповідає
іншим жінкам, які, як і вона, втратили дітей.
Вони створили
групу взаємодопомоги, у якій вже понад 800 осіб.
Серед них - і Заріма Гадзієва,
мати Руслана, за яким послідкувала
в Сирію донька Петімаат.
Моя донька дуже слухняна була.
Вона дуже довіряла своєму чоловіку.
Він наказав - вона поїхала.
- А ви не ображені на матір Руслана за те,
що її син забрав вашу доньку?
Присягаюся, що не ображена! Бо якщо чесно, на все воля Аллаха.
Значить, вони мали туди поїхати,
значить судилося, я так думаю.
Глибока віра - одна з причин, через яку ІД
вдалося завербувати їхніх дітей,
кажуть ці матері в аеропорту Грозного.
Вони збираються тут в надії на те,
що їхні діти повернуться на батьківщину
рейсом з Туреччини.
Я майже постійно тут буваю.
В польоті, так би мовити. Дома практично не буваю.
Мені залишитися не можна, дітей треба шукати.
Після того, як Росія оголосила про перемогу над
терористами ІД, із Сирії та Іраку
повертаються десятки чеченців.
Петімаат Саламова все ще сподівається,
що незабаром зможе обійняти свою доньку.
Якщо вона ще жива…